Prédiabetes, será que dá para levar
apenas com controle de dieta e bons
hábitos e sem usar remédios? Imagina que
você foi ao laboratório, pegou o
resultado e lá está pré-dia, dá um frio
na barriga, né? A pergunta que vem na
hora é: doutor, dá para seguir esse
remédio só com controle e bons hábitos?
A boa notícia é, na maioria das vezes,
pode ser que sim. E hoje eu vou te
mostrar passo a passo como virar esse
jogo com abordagem prática. na vida
real. Antes, rapidinho, pré-diabetes é
quando a glicose fica acima do normal,
mas ainda não chegou no nível de
diabetes. Em geral, isso aparece como
hemoglobina glicada entre 5,7 e 6,3,
glicemia de jejum por volta de 100 a 125
e a curva de 2 horas da glicose entre
140 e 199. É o sinal amarelo do corpo
pedindo mudança. E por que que eu digo
que dá para fazer a reversão? Porque
temos estudos grandes mostrando isso. O
clássico programa de prevenção ao
diabetes, o DPP, comparou três caminhos:
estilo de vida, metiformina e placebo,
que é píulo de farinha. Quem apostou em
hábitos de perder cerca de 7% de peso e
fazer atividade física regular, reduziu
o risco de virar diabetes em 58%.
Metiformina também ajudou mais menos,
olha só, 31%, ou seja, na vida real,
mudar a rotina é muito potente e tem
segmento de longo prazo confirmando esse
benefício, tá? Mas quando o remédio
entra na visão integrativa e também nas
diretrizes atuais, o primeiro passo é o
estilo de vida. Remédio pode ser
considerado se o risco for alto ou se
mesmo com mudança consistente os números
não melhorem.
Exemplos clássicos: índice de massa
corporal, MC a partir de 35, idade
abaixo de 60 anos, o histórico de
diabetes na gestação. Nesses perfis,
metiformina pode ser muito útil, mas
repare, é ferramenta e não atalho. E nos
casos sobrepeso barra obesidade com
pré-diabetes, surgiram opções que atuam
forte no peso e de quebra reduzem a
chance de evoluir pra diabetes. Estudos
com semaglutida e tirepatida,
que são muito usados para controle de
peso, mostraram queda expressiva na
progressão para diabetes e mais gente
voltando à glicemia normal, sempre
nesses casos com compimento médico e
foco em hábitos. Agora bora pro plano
prático. O cateto fantástico da
abordagem funcional. Comida de verdade,
movimento inteligente, som de qualidade,
gestão de estresse com metas simples e
mensuráveis. Primeiro, comida de verdade
não é sobre passar fome, é sobre
escolher o que você vai comer. Pense
assim: metade do prato com vegetais, um
quarto com proteína de verdade, seja
ovos, peixe, frango, cortes magros ou
até mesmo cortes gordos, se for uma
carne de qualidade. E 1/4 com
carboidratos mais inteligentes, feijões,
lentilhas, raízes e grãos integrais. Se
puder, reduza as farinhas refinadas ao
máximo possível. Corte o açúcar líquido,
refrigerantes e sucos e corte os
ultraprocessados. Eles inflamam, causam
resistência à insulina. Duas trilhas têm
boa evidência. A mediterrânea,
mediterrânea com azeite, nozes, peixes e
fibras, que reduz incidência de diabetes
até sem grande perda de peso. E a linha
mais baixa em carboidratos ou low carb
ou acetogênica, que costuma achar a
hemoglumina glicada, os triglicerides.
Escolha a que você consegue fazer de
maneira sustentada. Constância ganha do
tudo e nada. Segundo, movimento
inteligente. A meta que funciona na
prática é pelo menos 150 minutos por
semana de atividade aeróbica moderada.
Pode ser 30 minutos, cinco vezes por
semana, espalhadas em três ou mais dias,
sem ficar mais de dois dias seguidos
parado. Some dois a três sessões de
musculação na semana. Construir
preservar nossa massa muscular é uns
antídotos contra a resistência insulina.
Se puder, caminhe de 10 a 15 minutos
após as refeições, vai ajudar a domar o
pico de glicose. Terceiro, sono. Parece
detalhe, mas não é. No mirmal bagunça
hormônios da fome, piora a
acessibilidade insulina e aumenta o
risco de diabetes. Mirar 7 a 8 horas com
rotina regular é um grande investimento
metabólico e o seu corpo agradece.
Quarto, estresse e rotina. Respiração,
pausa ativa, luz da manhã, contato
social. Tudo isso desliga o modo alerta
crônico. Na prática, 5 minutos de
respiração diafragmática duas vezes ao
dia, já ajudam a reduzir impulsos por
açúcar. É simples, barato e poderoso. E
quais metas eu miro, doutor? Vamos de
indicadores fáceis. perder de 5 a 10%
peso ao longo de alguns meses já traz
melhora relevante na glicemia e nos
lipídios. Reduzir 2 a 4 cm de
circunferência abdominal e colocar o
corpo em movimento toda semana.
Importantíssimo. No laboratório, buscar
hemoglobina glicada abaixo de 5,7,
glicemia de jejum abaixo de 90 e, se
possível melhorar HDL e baixar a
prbicérides. Com que frequência eu
confiro isso? Em quem tem pré-diabetes,
a checagem formal pro diagnóstico
diabetes é no mínimo anual e o
acompanhamento clínico costuma ser a
cada três ou se meses para ajustar as
metas. Se puder fazer um período curto
com o sensor ou capilar após as
refeições, pode ser aquele sensor do
braço ou até o que fura o dedo, pode
sininar muito sobre como o seu corpo
reage aos alimentos. É aprendizado e não
paranoia. E se mesmo fazendo tudo certo,
os números não caírem, aí entra a
conversa franca com o seu médico. Dá
para considerar meteformina nos perfis
de maior risco ou quando o excesso de
peso é parte central da história,
terapias que dão suporte à perda de
peso, como as já citadas, sempre junto
com a reeducação.
A lógica é usar as ferramentas certas
pelo tempo certo, enquanto você
consolida hábitos que sustentem o
resultado. Isso é muito importante.
Resumo, sim, é possível seguir esse
remédio com controle e bons hábitos e a
ciência tem respaldo para isso. Foque no
básico bem feito, prato caprichado e
comida de verdade. 150 minutos de
movimento por semana, mais musculação,
sono de 7 a 8 horas e rotina menos
caótica. Vai medindo, comemorando
pequenas vitórias e ajustando o plano.
Se precisar de medicação, sem drama, ela
entra como aliada, não como muleta. Na
abordagem integrativa, a meta é a mesma:
te devolver autonomia metabólica. Isso
começa hoje, no próximo prato, no
próximo passo, na próxima noite de sono.
Estamos junto.